let's just speak together about yes
let's think about an example because I
heard somebody saying you know it's been
a while since you've done these kinds of
questions before on that a five sheet I
gave you so let's walk through an actual
concrete like together make sure you
doing things in the right way okay so
let's pick out an actual focus let's put
it somewhere pretty standard like -
water okay
let's define the directrix let's put a
nice envelope - for all right now what
will we do if we define the eccentricity
or whatever shape is going to be defined
by this focus and this directrix let's
make one okay now really you're gonna
end up where we started but you're not
always gonna end up there because we're
going to change this value later on okay
so just so if this is what we're working
out okay PS that's a point to another
point so it's just a 2 point formula
right what are we gonna get once I make
it right
yes well X minus zero square okay
because there's should have said this
your name there's the X there's a zero
okay so x squared plus what good okay
this is point two point
what if I go to the right hand side give
you a tip it's a fraction what's on the
top
okay let's course that's possible this
is a point to a line okay so we ought to
be able to say at this point
perpendicular distance going on okay
it's got to come that quickly if not
that means may have some revision of
parabola blockers to do okay because you
don't want to be taking that long in
exam to work out what you're gonna do
let alone actually work it out okay so
perpendicular distance formula what
you've got on the top I'm just gonna
quite the formula just for the same
thing since it took you a while to get
there you're gonna have a x1 plus B plus
C which is easy to remember because just
like the general form involved in a
straight line on the square root of odds
on remember it's good it's just it's
Pythagoras isn't it that's the
hypotenuse number one oh yeah all right
now in this case X moment to be 1 plus C
where are you giving that a B and C huh
hmm so it's from this straight line okay
now a B and C obviously it's depends on
you having that in general form which it
is not right now okay so what is it in
general form okay I'm even going to
sleep the zero at the front right
because there are zero lots of X 1 Y now
the reason why I write in that organ way
it's just so I can bring it directly
down to here that's exactly what you're
going to write on the top okay so what
are we going to here I'm going to on
yesterday you are now by the way you
can't just go ahead and write Y plus 4
then that's fine okay but I'm message
I've been doing this for years and I
still do this way any suggestions why
why might it be a good idea and after
you but why might it be
because you want to attend your
interests to put your work sure that not
just the market can understand it okay
we like to understand people's work but
so that when you come back and you're
checking it's easy to determine where
your errors have come from if you've got
them okay now if you're right life is
for you probably gonna be fun because a
pretty simple example but if you get it
wrong okay
how are you gonna make it easy for
yourself to find it and this is one of
the ways okay so write it out anything
for money is important a squared plus B
squared
there's my a there's my made again we're
gonna write it in more just so I make
sure I don't actually screw up the
formula okay great so what are we going
okay now what would be my next step
before I watch this son left hand side
what will be the next thing that you
would do you're trying to so get me
pretty the walkers what do you do scrape
the sides so let's do that
okay suggestions No
what am i trying to get to in the end
what's right what kind of form am i
trying to get you now see you you kind
of had the advantage in that you know
this is not the first time your manners
you know from the beginning what kind of
shape you want to get right so you
probably want to put it in a form that's
going to make it easy to work out what
the features of this thing are yeah so
you want to get saved probably because
your wife's words are gonna cancel
you probably want y equals something and
then you'll save you the characteristics
of the ground okay so let's go ahead and
do that what do we got here
that checkup okay so
okay great I'm done right what can we
tell about it it's a crab a lot it's
kind of needs to lose some weight what's
really shallow at the bottom there and
it's symmetrical about the y-axis and
you can work out what that's your goods
I'm not that big a deal okay a problem
just like we expected okay a century
says he all right yeah he's interesting
one my question to you is what happens
if we change the centricity what are we
going to end up with yeah look sometime
I want you to try out everything being
the same okay same point same focus and
directrix but this time I want you to
try out what happens if the eccentricity
is a huff okay now before you put pen to
paper okay now just start to compute
this thing right what might you guess
this is so important in maths you always
need to think about what might you get
at the end before you actually get there
okay because always illuminating right
this is the ratio this is what these
centricity is here some PD to the focus
to the directions that ratio is 1/2 what
does that tell you there's a ratio right
if I said for instance the ratio of how
many how many donuts
I can eat versus how many donuts
Elian can eat right is you know 1 over 2
what does that tell you ok who can eat
more donuts
you can even do it are you sure okay
that's right boys this is the moment I
love by the way you like yeah it's uh
it's fine and then someone just says are
you sure really
no no he's messing with us and then you
you're right you're right it's Ellie
Ellie Incantatem ordinary enough and
there's no easy way to see it is you
know if we rewrote this as a ratio
rather than fraction you'd write it like
this
Elian equals 1 to 2 it's kind of obvious
it's like well that's the one and that's
the two you're getting twice um anything
fun ok sorry I just like messing with
you that's all all right now therefore
what does this mean this means that
wherever the points are we're gonna try
and draw them closer to the focus and
further from the directrix okay what's
that gonna mean so I'm gonna get you to
spend some time computing it give it a
go try and make it guess if you can
before you have just that computing as
to what it might look like is it gonna
be another problem really wait no is
that lunch so we're gonna what are we
lunch to now looks great we're still
here right that's like a good okay so
there's the shape see what you get and
if you have an answer coming Kolby oh go